this part is conspiracy but I think
there's a group of Elites that believe
in population control and I think that's
why they're doing it and that's why 80
percent of planned parenthoods in the US
are in minority communities the black
population the US will be doubled today
everyone yeah she referred to black
people as weeds and so it's like if Nike
was founded by a racist people would be
on the streets why is this okay
especially when Margaret sanger's
grandson they talk about how they want
to Market it to minority women and they
talk about how they want to they make it
a woman of color issue and like that's
that's how they Market it to minority in
that her project it was called the
n-word project her grandson is still
doing it he's in New York he was the
head of Planned Parenthood in all of New
York and he was interviewed about Roe
versus Wade and he uses the same
language like this affects women of
color when anyone can get an abortion
it's not it's not specific